Jonathan majors has officially been
fired by Marvel Studios after he was
found guilty in court yesterday and now
all eyes are looking at Marvel Studios
wondering what's their next move how do
they now move forward in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with or without Kang
the Conqueror being the main villain of
the MCU well according to multiple
reports from many different insiders it
looks like we have a decent idea of what
Marvel studios's plans are moving
forward in the MCU and it sounds like
they are indeed going to move forward
without King and we did talk yesterday
about how Avengers the King Dynasty is
most likely not the title of that
anymore in fact one Insider yesterday
has backed up his claim that he made in
the past that the film really is no
longer Avengers the King Dynasty but
it's simply Avengers 5 right now but we
could essentially have a title for it
which we're going to talk about in this
video and of course talk about how
Marvel is moving forward and what their
plans and focus are going to be in in
the MCU so if you're new be sure to
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss out on any of the latest MCU news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items the winner picks one
item and we pick one winner at the end
of each month now based off of what some
insiders are stating it sounds like
we're not going to see the next big bad
the big bad of The multivers Saga until
either right before Avengers Secret Wars
or in Avengers Secret Wars itself what
Marvel Studios is apparently going to do
is focus on individual stories with a
plan of slowly building up to the threat
that we'll eventually see in Avengers
Secret Wars however this does not mean
that they are scrapping everything that
has happened in Phase 4 in Phase five
I've seen a lot of people talking about
this online but let's be clear Marvel
Studios is not scrapping the Multiverse
Saga it is still the Multiverse Saga the
Multiverse is still going to play a huge
part of it Loki season 1 and season 2
still happened Loki still made the
sacrifice to allow the Multiverse to
exist plus we have projects like
Deadpool 3 coming up which is a huge
multiversal film plus Spider-Man now way
home and Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness Marvel is already
too far into the Multiverse Saga to
completely scrap it and go a new
Direction the Multiverse exists
incursions are happening and our
universe the 616 universe is going to
fall apart Alex P from the cosmic circus
replied to this tweet today stating they
don't need to recast king marvel needs
to compl completely pivot away from the
entire King story line and everyone can
just pretend phase 4 never happened I
understand this thinking and I'm sure it
was an option for Marvel Studios but
here's what Alex P said in reply to this
they aren't going to do that their plan
at the moment is to focus on individual
story arcs like Devil Reign the rise of
the midnight Suns the coming of mutants
while slowly building up to a threat
beyond the Multiverse that we will never
see until 616 is in Absol solute
shambles now I don't think this is a
terrible idea and I definitely don't
think that Marvel Studios should scrap
the whole Multiverse Saga because let's
face it they could they could simply say
phase four and phase five were a
different Saga they were the Multiverse
Saga we had some Multiverse events
happen in these two phases but now in
phase six and Beyond we're going to just
dive right into the mutant Saga and it
sounds like that's somewhat what they're
doing according to Daniel rpk right now
Marvel Studios is working on their first
X-Men project which could be introduced
before Secret Wars because it would
definitely get people excited for the
MCU again with the introduction of the
mutants which Marvel really needs right
now especially with the firing of
Jonathan major as king and it would
tease phase seven to get people excited
for that as well plus mutants are going
to be a huge part of the Multiverse Saga
either way because Deadpool 3 and Secret
Wars we're going to see a lot of X-Men
but slowly building up to a villain who
is seemingly going to be controlling the
Multiverse is a great way to go while
focusing on other major teams and
characters this is a good way to go
focus more on the individual stories
because let's face it the storytelling
hasn't been let's just say what it was
in the past we've had some good ones
here and there but nothing compared to
like what the MCU used to be but as far
as the villain is concerned it seems
like Alex Perez is possibly teasing the
beyonder now according to previous
reports a king beyonder variant was
supposed to be the main villain for
Secret Wars and there's no reason that
Marvel Studios simply can't keep the
beyonder part of that there's no reason
why they can't just ditch the king part
and keep the beyonder as the main
villain after all that is what happens
in the comics in both Stories the
beyonder is behind everything and you
could introduce him very slowly in the
MCU but he is not the only villain that
works of course Dr Doom would work as
well as Dr Doom is really the other main
villain of the secret War Stories now I
mentioned we could possibly have a title
for the next Avengers film because
according to recent reports King Dynasty
is no longer King Dynasty it's just
Avengers 5 and according to Insider Jeff
Snider Avengers King Dynasty is
essentially Secret Wars part one now
with the actual Secret Wars film being
part two yesterday he tweeted scoop
confirmed I told you that the next
Avengers movie wouldn't be called the
King Dynasty the name King only conjures
thoughts of Jonathan major I said this
before it was revealed that Marvel hired
Waldron and stood by it when the trades
kept calling it Kang Dynasty and he
backed up this in a high report from The
Hollywood Reporter the highlighted part
reads in November Marvel hired Loki
Creator Michael Waldren to work on a new
draft of what was to have been Kang
Dynasty but is now being referred to as
Avengers 5 according to sources then
Jeff Snyder tweeted again effectively
Secret Wars is now a two-part conclusion
to The Avengers Saga and we won't dive
too much into that it's very clear that
moving forward in the next Saga it's
really going to focus on the X-Men of
the Fantastic 4 but but the Avengers
will still be there they're not just
going to go away but they won't be the
main focus anymore now something really
important to note is that Marvel Studios
has probably had these plans in place
for a very long time now some people are
asking the question how could these
people know this already they just fired
Jonathan mjor well it's really simple
Marvel Studios and Disney knew that it
was a possibility that Jonathan Majors
was going to be found guilty and if he
was to be found guilty which he was they
would have to have a plan in place on
how to move forward after they're not
just going to sit and wait to find out
what happens then go oh crap now we have
to figure out what to do no since March
they have been figuring out what they
want to do if he is found guilty and how
to move forward in the MCU either
without king or recasting him so Marvel
has most likely had a plan in place for
a pretty long time they've essentially
had 9 months to make a contingency plan
in case Jonathan major was found guilty
and they had to fire him it is also
worth noting that they could have
actually let go of Jonathan major as K
the Conqueror a little bit ago just
simply haven't announced it public
publicly for whatever reason but I'll
summarize what the reported plan is now
Marvel Studios will move forward without
kinging the Conqueror he could appear
for continuity purposes in the MCU but
if he does appear it will either be CGI
or they will recast the character and a
new actor will play him and he'll
probably usher in a new villain if you
watch my video yesterday you know that
it's really easy to say that Kang is not
a problem anymore thanks to Loki and the
TVA pruning every King that they could
find it's actually quite simple moving
forward Marvel Studios will begin to
focus on writing quality projects
focusing on introducing new Heroes and
new teams like the midnight Suns this
makes sense because we know that pretty
much everything is going to come
together and every team is going to come
together in Avengers Secret Wars then
they'll work their way up to Avengers
Secret Wars part one and part two the
Multiverse will fall apart and a
multiversal Avengers team will save
everything but then moving forward after
that we will have a soft reboot of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe which we need
now I'm not saying that this Multiverse
Saga isn't salvageable I think it really
really is and I think Deadpool 3 is
going to give us a lot of Hope and if
Marvel can just nail some really good
projects and nail a new villain it could
still be an absolutely incredible Saga
but let me know your thoughts about what
Marvel studios's new plan is in the
comments down below and who do you think
should be the new villain should it be
Doom should it be the beyonder or
somebody else let us know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe to stay up to date on all
the latest MCU news you can always
follow us on in Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof